Alice is in my she'll stay silent down
there so she has a good shot at getting
back to us sir Isabelle this is captain
cutter I know who you are
James cutter captain of the spirit of
fire
they're supposed to be lost with all
hands not so lost it seems what happened
down there I need to know what we're up
against
Isabelle
Isabelle report sir
five months ago the portal from the ark
to earth shut down without warning a
month later he arrived he
the brute their leader his name is a
tree ox during the war the Covenant used
his clan as expendable muscle told them
dying in battle would speed their holy
journey
forty at a time that carelessly sent
them in 40 to break the frontlines
forward to die for beliefs not their own
no never returned until he did so battle
by battle war by war 39 brothers at a
time
a tree ox was born with every victory
his legend
favourite of the Covenant grew
eventually both were impossible to
conceal
and they tried to banish him and
everything we know about the covenants
thousand-year history patriarchs was the
first to defy the covenant and survive
and his defiance inspired others
Patriarchs and has vanished raided
covenant resources cutting a swath
across the galaxy growing in strength
with each of attack
gathering killers and mercenaries to his
side the Covenant had two targets in
those years humanity and atriums they
almost got us
a tree ox they never came close
that's what you're up against and all
you've got is one old ship and half a
crew to staff her we need to run as far
and as fast as we can we are just one
ship and an old one at that but here we
are thirty years past what anyone could
ask of us our war is gone
lives we had her gone
the world's we knew that moved on
and now all that we may have left those
standing beside us and the duty that
defines us battle after battle fighting
side-by-side together where you see half
a crew is a moment I see family
courage
and a thousand heroes who swore to fight
their way through hell before they ever
ever turn their backs and run and where
you see one old ship
I see home
and that is always worth fighting for
if we don't stop a tree arcs now we
leave the galaxies at the mercy of a
Moscow
so no Isabelle we won't be running
anywhere today sir yes sir